good evening my name is Isabella Reggie
and I'm a freshman here at Hillsdale
planning on studying French and
journalism and I have the honor tonight
to introduce Miss Heather McDonald miss
McDonald is the Thomas W Smith fellow at
the Manhattan Institute and a
contributing editor of city journal
she earned a BA from Yale University an
MA in English from Cambridge University
and a JD from Stanford Law School she
writes for several newspapers and
periodicals including The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times the New
Criterion and Public Interest
and is the author of four books
including the war on cops how the new
attack on law and order makes everyone
less safe and the diversity delusion how
race and gender pandering corrupt the
university and undermine our culture
fourth coming September 2018 I had the
honor of participating in Miss
McDonald's Pulliam fellow class this
past week and a half and I have to say
she is an incredible woman she is a
fearless journalist and she has showed
us that no topic is untouchable and so
please join me in welcoming miss Heather
McDonald
thank you thank you very much reg a you
get an A it's been a privilege to teach
at Hillsdale these past two weeks and to
meet your wonderful students I keep
having to pinch myself to grasp that I'm
at a place where teaching Shakespeare
and Milton is not about to lead at any
minute to a strident protest against
cisnormative patriarchal racist
privilege it's heaven I didn't know it
existed I want to thank professor Miller
for inviting me and give special thanks
to Margie King for making my visit here
so enjoyable now I've been speaking on
college campuses other than Hillsdale
recently you know what that means I've
received the walk out the storm the
stage and at Claremont McKenna College
in California the blockade that
prevented anyone from attending my talk
at Columbia Law School a student gave me
the finger during the entirety of my
talk so-called students of color at
Pomona College called me a quote fascist
white supremacist Warhawk trans folk
queer folk classist and ignorant of
interlocking systems of domination that
produced the lethal conditions under
which oppressed peoples are forced to
live end quote
so to actually have an audience still in
its seats and apparently willing to
listen is an unusual experience for me
that's gonna take me a few minutes to
get used to at these other venues I was
speaking about the police tonight
however I'm going to address a different
but equally volatile topic the fallout
from the me2 movement our world is about
to be transformed thanks to me too I'm
not referring here to a cessation of
sexual predation in the work
place if that were the only consequence
of the movement it would clearly be a
force for good but its effects are going
to be more sweeping and more destructive
me too is going to unleash a new torrent
of gender and race quotas throughout the
economy and culture on the theory that
all disparities in employment and
institutional representation are due to
harassment and bias the resulting
distortions in decision-making will be
largely invisible we will usually not
know of those superior candidates for a
job who are passed over in the drive for
gender parity but the net consequence
will be a loss of American
competitiveness and scientific
achievement pressures for so-called
diversity of course defined reductively
by gonads and melanin are nothing new
since the 1990s every mainstream
institution has lived in terror of three
lethal words all white male just one of
those damning epithets alone can produce
paroxysms of self abasement Silicon
Valley startups and science labs quake
before the label all are mostly male
their varied ethnic demographics earned
them no protection from the diversity
racket the New York Times recently
criticized the board of fashion giant
H&M for being quote entirely white we
can therefore infer that there were
females on the H&M board or else the
times would have broken out the biggest
gun of all entirely white male when
those two categories of alleged
privileged white and male overlap an
activist is in the diversity sweet spot
his power over an institution at its
zenith
but however pervasive the diversity
imperative was before
the Miche movement is going to make the
previous three decades look like the
Golden Age of meritocracy no mainstream
institution will hire promote or
compensate without an exquisite
calculation of gender and race ratios
males in general and white males in
particular will have to pass a very high
bar of qualifications in order to
justify further deferring that Halcyon
moment of gender equity Hollywood in the
media are already showing the me2 effect
at this year's Oscars awards lunch the
president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences prefaced his
remarks by noting that he was a quote 75
year old white man President John Bailey
was trying to get out ahead of the curve
since if he hadn't pointed out this
shameful status feminist Crusaders in
the press and the industry would have
done so for him witness actress Natalie
Portman sneer in presenting the Best
Director prize of the 2018 Golden Globe
Awards quote and here are the all male
nominees such shall of bean-counting is
now going to become the automatic
response to any perceived lack of
diversity in entertainment naturally
Bailey announced reparations for the
Academy's predominant white male status
henceforth it would quote balance gender
race ethnicity and religion in all its
activities and would double its female
female and minority members by 2020 this
was not enough of course outside the
lunch the Hispanic media coalition
protested the lack of Hispanic
representation among Oscar nominations
and acting roles the prospect of
left-wing entertainment moguls having to
sacrifice their box office judgment to
identity politics is an unalloyed
pleasure
and of little consequence to the society
at large but quota izing sadly will
hardly be limited to Hollywood major
publishing houses are analyzing their
author lists by gender and race and
making publishing decisions accordingly
what books get reviewed and who reviews
them is going to be increasingly
determined by gender and race there are
no major newspapers that are not
tallying reporter and op-ed by lines as
well as the topics they cover by gender
and race in 2005 professional feminist
Susan esteridge preposterous Lee accused
editor Michael Kinsley then running the
Los Angeles Times opinion pages of
excluding female writers naturally
esteridge ignored the fact that males
are disproportionately interested in
public affairs as demonstrated by
lopsided sex ratios among op-ed
submissions and letters to the editor
eighty-seven percent of contributors to
Wikipedia are male there are no
gatekeepers at Wikipedia contributions
are anonymous and open to all wikipedia
is therefore a perfect natural
experiment testing which sex on average
is more oriented towards highly
fact-based realms without the
possibility of anyone shouting that
sexist gatekeepers are keeping out all
those would be female wiki contributors
now however sterile bean-counting
exercises such as estrogen have gone
in-house in response to the me2 movement
the New York Times created a quote
gender editor who presides over a quote
gender initiative to infuse questions of
gender throughout all the times coverage
a recent front page product
of this me to initiative covered the
earth-shattering problem of NFL
cheerleaders to wit they have a dress
code and are forbidden from fat earn
izing with players despite these
allegedly patriarchal conditions females
beg to be hired to the puzzlement of The
Times corporate boardrooms executive
suites and management structures are
going to be scoured for gender and race
imbalances diversity trainers are
already sensing a windfall from me to
gender diversity and inclusion were the
dominant themes at this January's World
Economic Forum in Davos Switzerland the
conference was shared exclusively by
women windows were in blaze blaze and
with slogans like diversity is good for
business and gender equality is a social
and economic issue CEOs shared their
techniques for achieving gender equity
it's actually quite simple explained the
CEO of Hilton pay managers based on
their record of hiring and promoting
females and minorities
never mind that by introducing
irrelevant factors such as race and
gender into an evaluation process you
will inevitably get less qualified hires
US banks and financial institutions are
facing pressure from shareholder groups
to release data on the number and
compensation of females and minorities
in their upper ranks a confession I vote
against any female in a board proxy
ballot because I know that the pressure
for gender proportionality drives the
selection of nominees immediate
punishment befall z-- anyone in business
who has the courage to criticize the war
on merit the chief creative officer of
advertising firm M&C Saatchi wrote in
October 2017 that he was quote bored of
diversity being prioritized
her talent endquote Sacchi atoned for
this heresy with a frenzy of female
hiring and promotions amazingly a white
male actually squeaked into the
presidency of the Federal Reserve Bank
of New York this month
to the outrage of diverse acress don't
be surprised if he's the last white male
to do so New York senator Kirsten
Gillibrand sniffed quote the New York
Fed has never been led by a woman or a
person color of a person of color and
that needs to change and quote the new
Fed president's progress as the New York
Times called it in quote diversifying
the senior leadership of the Federal
Bank Reserve Bank of San Francisco
undoubtedly made his unfortunate race
and sex more palatable to the search
committee me too enforcers are even
going after classical music New Yorker
music critic Alex Ross triggered outrage
against the Chicago Symphony Orchestra
and the Philadelphia Orchestra in
February when he tweeted that they had
programmed no female composers in their
2018-2019 season never mind that the
Chicago Symphony Orchestra was even then
performing Jennifer higden's low brass
concerto at concerto at Carnegie Hall a
piece commissioned by the Chicago
Philadelphia and Baltimore orchestras it
is ludicrous to suggest that these
institutions are discriminating against
female composers but Ross and his
followers demand affirmative programming
quotas the public radio show performance
today picked up the theme and ran a
series of programs in March about gender
and racial inequities in classical music
at a time of diminishing classical music
audiences it is profoundly irresponsible
to
rekt the poison of identity politics at
our most precious musical institutions
doing so only encourages potential young
listeners and culturally ignorant
philanthropists I'm thinking of you Bill
Gates to stay away the fact is over most
of music history the greatest composers
have been male no amount of digging
through score archives
however useful that enterprise may be
for discovering unfamiliar works is
going to unearth a female counterpart to
Bach Mozart Beethoven Schubert Chopin or
Brahms among other geniuses so what we
should simply be down on our knees in
gratitude for the music that these
geniuses created Orchestra boards will
pay penance for their own inadequate
diversity by a mad rush on female
conductors whose numbers are minuscule
it was already difficult two years ago
to land a US conducting position for a
universally esteemed white male
conductor reports his agent now it would
be nearly impossible the agent believes
adding quote if I had a trans conductor
I'd be rich academia the source of
identity politics will double down on
its diversity quota izing in the wake of
me too in March the Chronicle of Higher
Education and the diversity chair of
Stanford University's history department
went into diversity meltdown over a
history conference that Hoover
Institution Fellow Neil Ferguson had
organized though Ferguson had invited
females to speak none had accepted not
good enough Ferguson should have
suspended the conference entirely unless
he could persuade females and minorities
to participate
according to the Stanford history
diversity chair naturally this diversity
bureaucrat did not identify any
scholarly gaps that resulted from the
actual lineup Stanford University was
itself so shaken by this calamitous
panel that had issued a statement on
behalf of the President and provost
assuring the public that it hadn't made
its concerns about the lack of diversity
known to the organizers the stem
department's science technology
engineering and math have been under
enormous pressure from the federal
government to hire by gender and race
now they are creating their own internal
diversity enforcers notwithstanding the
massive diversity bureaucracy that
already has taken over universities as a
whole UCLA's engineering department now
has its own diversity Dean the director
of UCLA's women in engineering program
justified this Sinha cure with the usual
role model argument for gender and race
conscious decision-making quote female
students let me know how much they
appreciate seeing a woman of color in
front of their classroom she told the
UCLA student newspaper question why not
appreciate seeing the most qualified
scholar in front of your classroom any
female student who thinks she needs a
female professor in order to envision a
scientific career has declared herself a
follower rather than a pioneer and a
follower based on a characteristic that
is irrelevant to intellectual
achievement if it really were the case
that a role model of the same gender is
necessary to succeed it would be
impossible to alter the gender balance
of a field assuming that such a mission
is worthwhile he
it is not absent a finding of actual
discrimination Marie Curie did not need
female role models to investigate
radioactivity she was motivated by a
passion to understand the world that
should be reason enough for anyone to
plunge headlong into the search for
knowledge Silicon Valley is a me-too
bonanza waiting to happen it is not for
nothing that the Mountain View
headquarters of Google is referred to as
the Google campus the culture of the
Silicon Valley BMF is an echo chamber of
shrill academic victimology managers and
employees reflexively label dissenters
from left-wing orthodoxy misogynists and
racists it is assumed that the lack of
proportional representation of female
black and Hispanic engineers at the
company is due to bias on the part of
every other type of engineer in August
2017 Google fired computer engineer
James damm more for writing a memo
suggesting that the lack of 50/50 gender
proportionality at Google and other tech
firms may be due not to bias but to
different career predilections on the
part of males and females
he cited solid psychological research
establishing that on average males and
females are attracted to different types
of work males to more abstract idea
centered work females to more human
centered relational activities damar was
not disparaging the scientific skills of
the female engineers at Google he was
trying to explain why there were not
more of them nevertheless Google accused
d'amour of using harmful gender
stereotypes that put Google's females at
risk
of trauma Google's adoption of the
rhetoric of academic victimology to
justify firing d'amour was bad enough
but in January 2018 the National Labor
Relations Board released a memo
upholding Google's actions on the same
grounds de Moura claimed had engaged in
discrimination and sexual harassment by
employing quote harmful gender
stereotypes the reasoning behind the
memo puts every academic scientist
researching the biological and
psychological differences between the
sexes at risk of his job the ideological
imperatives of feminism are trumping the
search for scientific truth this is a
dangerous place for society to be in the
next month
a former YouTube and Google recruiter
further documented the quota mentality
that now reigns in Silicon Valley he had
refused to obey and edict to purge white
males from consideration for from enter
for entry level engineering interviews
the recruiter was promptly fired Google
would rather not even know about
potentially groundbreaking tech talent
if it comes in the wrong color and shape
such distortions of meritocracy will
become even more intense following me to
the mad rush of investor funding into
biotech fraudster firm theranos was
undoubtedly due in large part to the sex
of its founder Elizabeth Holmes claimed
to have invented a mobile blood testing
device even as her claims about this
largely fictitious device unraveled
investors continued to give her
unqualified support her blue chip board
boasted two former secretaries of state
and then head of US Central Command Jim
mattis now Secretary of Defense
hilariously
the me to obsess New York Times The
Pines that it was quote surprising how
long Holmes was allowed to operate
before regulators stepped in actually
what is surprising is that they stepped
in at all given the dominant narrative
that the dearth of female startups is
due to sexism on the part of venture
capitalists and regulators despite the
billions of dollars that governments
companies and foundations have poured
into increasing the number of females in
stem the gender proportions of the hard
scientists of the hard sciences have not
changed much over the years this is to
be expected given mounting confirmation
of the differences in interests and
aptitudes between the sexes
study after study has shown that females
gravitate towards different types of
jobs than men as James Day more fatally
observed females on average tend to
choose fields that are perceived to make
the world a better place according to
the common understanding of that phrase
a preschool teacher in the Bronx
profiled by Bloomberg News exemplifies
such a choice she has a BA in
neuroscience but opted not to go to
medical school so as to have an impact
on poor and minority children her salary
is a fraction of what she could earn as
a clinical or research neurologist but
pay is not her top motivation for
choosing a job she said even within the
broad stem umbrella females seek jobs
that are seen as directly helping others
by a two-to-one ratio over males females
make up 75% of workers and health
related jobs but only 25% of workers and
computer jobs and 14% of engineering
workers nearly 82 percent of abstract of
obstetrics and gynaecology medical
residents in 2016 were female but no one
is complaining about gender bias against
males
and in a resounding blow to the feminist
narrative about bias and stem it turns
out that the more gender equality in a
country the lower the percentage of
females in stem majors and fields the
more careers that are open to females
the less likely they are to choose math
or science finally there is the most
taboo subject of all the non identical
distribution of high end math skills
males outnumber females on both the
bottom rung of math cluelessness and the
top rung of math insight in the u.s.
there are two point five males in the
top Oh 1% of math ability for every
female in that category this is not a
matter of gender bias and cultural
conditioning gender differences in math
precocity show up as early as
kindergarten given these different
distributions of interests and skills
the only way to engineer gender
proportionality in the hard sciences is
to put a ceiling on male hires no matter
how gifted until enough females can be
induced to enter the field to balance
out the males and indeed the National
Science Foundation seems to be moving in
that direction it is announced that
progress in science requires a quote
diverse stem workforce this is
undoubtedly good news to China as it
furiously pushes ahead with its
unapologetically meritocratic system of
science training and research the rest
of us however should not be so thrilled
the me2 movement has uncovered real
abuses of power but the solution to
those abuses is not to replace valid
measures of achievement with irrelevance
ease like gender and race ironically the
best solution to sexual predation is not
more feminine ism it is less
by denying the differences between men
and women and by ridiculing the manly
virtues of gentlemen leanness and
chivalry and the female virtues of
modesty and prudence feminism dissolved
the civilizational restraints on the
male libido the boorish behavior that
has come to light such as bizarrely
masturbating in front of female
acquaintances would have been
unthinkable under a traditional concept
of sexual propriety such crude
exhibitionism would have been deemed a
violation of the lady's modesty and the
gentleman's dignity
now however with ladies and gentlemen
banished from our social universe and
indeed our language itself such behavior
is apparently no longer unthinkable Pot
Jay the feminists Western culture is in
fact the least patriarchal society in
human history rather than being forced
to veil females can parade themselves in
as scantily clad a manner as they choose
pop culture stars flaunt their
promiscuity every mainstream institution
is trying to hire and promote as many
females as possible as the me to moment
swells the demand for ever more
draconian diversity mandates a finding
in a Pew Research Center poll on
workplace equity is worth noting the
perception of bias is directly
proportional to the number of years the
perceiver has spent in an American
University
except for Hillsdale the persistent
claim of gender bias in other words is
ideological not empirical but after me
too it will have an even more disruptive
effect thank you for your attention
you